he said the most amazing thing to me he
says Pat no matter what you put your
money in with us nothing you're doing
right now in your life is going to make
higher returns than whatever you operate
look what he said whatever you operate
because operating I know how to grow in
scale of business you know how to
operate and grow this this didn't go to
where it did by pure luck you have a
system behind it you're a data guy
you're a numbers guy you're all that
stuff right
sooner I found out I'm an operator
that's my game I'm not a guy that's
going to build a 17 billion Auto real
estate portfolio that's not my game I'm
not a guy that's going to go out there
and you know be the next Bitcoin guy and
talk and I'm a maximil you know I'm not
that guy yeah I'm an operator I like
starting businesses building businesses
you got to take a piece of paper and
write out for yourself what excites you
what are you very good at and match
those two if what excites you matches
what you're very good at that's that's
peaking yeah if if what I'm doing I'm an
expert that is this but this excites me
as well as this that matches I'm solid